manhunt season 4 is now open
and for the first target agents are
tasked with locating bridget douglas
codename viper viper brings some
interesting additions to the story
including the first confirmed black tusk
recruitment from outside of the u.s
military
and a possible link to other waves of
division agents
that are yet to be activated
[Music]
viper is the only child of charles
douglas the co-founder of a military
equipment company
she grew up in a secluded luxurious
estate in the scottish highlands
after graduating from university viper
completed an eight-year stint in the sas
before taking a position in her father's
company douglas and harding
as a logistics and supply specialist
however when the dollar flu outbreak hit
she was immediately contacted by the
black tusk
yet this was after she was recruited by
the strategic homeland division
completely disregarding her father's
opposition to the idea she joined up the
btsu shortly after
fast forward a few months feylau has
sided with schaefer and the btsu
she was inducted into the group meeting
several prominent members
and viper was among them sas
that's impressive logistics and supply
specialist
not that impressive you shouldn't do
that do what
sell yourself short you are impressive
you didn't have to join the services
rich girl like you had other options
just because my father has money it
doesn't mean i'm some spoiled rich girl
i can take care of myself your record
proves that
you joined the black tusk in december
that's correct before you were activated
i was never activated
guess they're still saving some of us
for the real end times does schaefer
know your division
he never asked and i didn't think it was
worth bringing up until it was a problem
smart i like smart women
me too being that fey lau was the acting
division commander in new york
she would have had access to highly
confidential intel and was aware of
viper's recruitment
into the division viper was keeping this
information from schaefer
and she chose to hold this information
from him unless approached about it
she had spent her whole life having
people assume that she has it easy
everything given to her on a silver
platter and that she had no idea of the
stresses and complications that the
average person faced
but through issues with her father in
their earlier years she did her utmost
to separate herself from the privileged
lifestyle
and carve her own path and this just
happened to be in a direction that her
father wouldn't approve of
which probably only made the path that
much more appealing
following the outbreak charles douglas
can be seen talking to his business
partner
john harding
john the 27 years we spend building dna
have you ever known me to be a paranoid
lunatic of course not
but there is no conspiracy charles
everyone's just preparing all this panic
will die down
soon enough someone is freezing us out
we supply militaries for god's sake
if we can't book factory time this
company is going down the path
look forget about this conspiracy theory
of yours
there's no secret cabal trying to freeze
us out
let's just focus on sorting out this
mess i swear
something big is happening fine think
what you want
i don't have enough energy to fight you
on this right now
with the current state of washington dc
and the rest of america
it was having an effect on business with
the closing down of factories
and inadequate numbers to run them
charles was certain that there was
something going on
that was targeting dnh weapons
manufacturing
however not long after this conversation
john harding would pass away
due to complications from influenza
as the situation continued to get worse
in dc charles eventually relocated
to the white house where he is working
and our users turn very loosely
as the range officer in the shooting
range
as a father charles was very hard on
viper
she found him a difficult man to please
who was constantly critical towards
everything she did
and would often downplay her
achievements this in turn resulted in
know moving in life directions that were
against his will
although this meant she was forced to
grow up to be strong and independent
she still bears the scars of a very
critical upbringing
viper doesn't think particularly highly
of herself and tends to be a little
insecure around her abilities
you're sure he's at the white house
that's what kelso said he's running a
shooting range and drinking
dandelion coffee from a very fancy
espresso machine
huh well that sounds like my dad he's
doing great
found a way to make himself useful he
was lucky
never caught the virus and still has all
his parts aside from the dandelion
instead of his regular copy luak it
sounds like his life hasn't changed much
he's still in the lab getting people to
test his equipment and probably making
them feel really insecure about their
accuracy
you miss him of course but when
something like this happens
you have to do what you think is right
i'm glad we each found something
even if he is actively making my life
harder
which yeah that hasn't really changed
much either
leading up to the operation faye
discusses the role that viper will play
i'm best in a support role you don't
want to lead your own team i prefer to
be in a support role
i get that some people aren't cut out to
make the hard choices
oh that's not what i'm worried about
what are you worried about
being responsible for my team's life
you'll make sacrifices to save them
no that i'll consider their deaths an
acceptable loss
we know what we signed up for we assume
this is a suicide mission
if you make it back home that's the
unexpected outcome
you worried about survivor's guilt can't
be worried about something you can't
control and every mission i come back
from i never feel guilty
not about being the one that comes back
other [ __ ]
sure but never that i survived
viper isn't interested in leading a team
not because she's scared of the
responsibility
more that she's worried about treating
them as expendable
in her career she was always aware of
what they were there for and that there
was a chance
that they may never returned but in this
situation
the men she would lead would be relying
on her to keep them alive
regardless faye pushed her out of her
comfort zone and assigned her a squad
how's it feel good weird
i like being in charge but yeah it's
it's weird being the one people are
looking to for
guidance your team speaks highly of you
viper
you're a natural leader likeable kind
tough when you need to be
they respect you but aren't intimidated
by you
cool that's hard to pull off especially
for a woman
thanks i try not to be a [ __ ] i'm still
working on that one
to viper's surprise she was actually
quite suited to the task of leading a
team
she is a valuable and well-respected
leader
when instructed to do so viper set forth
executing her part in the operation
taking her band of btsu she started
creating havoc
in the southern districts of washington
dc
multiple sites of interest were captured
in west potomac
east mall south west and also the
pentagon
one by one the division took back these
areas eliminating all black tusks who
engaged them
eventually they managed to catch up with
viper although she put up a strong
resistance
the agents managed to put a stop to her
activities and take her down
in turn removing fey lau's first
lieutenant from the field
it isn't clear what viper's part in this
operation was but through continuing to
hunt down the remainder of the
lieutenants
phase plan and location should hopefully
become known
viper's story is an interesting addition
for a couple of reasons
firstly she's the first known operative
that the black tusk have recruited that
wasn't from the us military
secondly she say she was never activated
is this proof that there was a third
wave of division agents that were never
released
well to be honest i'm not convinced
barden schaefer was the man that knew
everything through the black task he has
ties within the government
who has feared him considerable intel on
the division including their agents
i find it very hard to believe that he
didn't know of her involvement with the
shd
regardless of whether she was activated
or not plus
was she just hiding her watch in
division gear this whole time
then there is our initial briefing on
this manhunt as kelso did with the other
manhunts we've had up until now
she gave us a quick rundown of the
targets we'll be coming up against
in her words viper dropped off the radar
not long after being activated in the
first wave
bridget douglas a callsign viper she's a
chemical logistics and supply specialist
dropped off our radar not long after
being activated in the first wave
so is viper lying about not being
activated
both to those around her and even
herself over time
or was kelso just wrong and merely
assumed
that doesn't really sound like a
particularly accurate briefing and what
would she gain from making that up kelso
must have gotten the intel from
somewhere
surely another thing that bugs me which
probably means absolutely nothing is the
fact that her watch is very obviously
red
which makes sense she's a rogue agent
after all but if we remember back to the
start
agents waiting to be activated were
usually notified by their watch
when the orange ring lit up they knew
that the next steps would be to make
their way to the safe house
and assemble with the rest of their cell
for her to be flagged as rogue would she
not have had to be activated as an
active agent first
are the watchers even able to do
anything before being activated
of course there really could be some
simple explanation for this like maybe
fey gave her a watch when assembling the
crew
perhaps it was activated when joining
the rogue network
but that doesn't really make sense
because if she was never activated in
the first place how would kini have
gotten in contact with her
plus she was working with the black
tusks so kinase certainly wouldn't have
helped them
i don't know with the limited amount of
information we've been given there are a
number of different rabbit holes we
could go down to try and explain
why or why not she chose to do this but
my opinion
is that she was activated either before
or while working with the black tusk
but for one reason or another she chose
not to tell barden or faye the truth
but what do you guys think let me know
otherwise i hope you've enjoyed this
video
and i'll catch you in the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]